Stephen Amell a little drama out there
on the ice rink gotta ask you how
because your daughter she doing okay no
my daughter cutting her finger on
television now she's fine she she she
was taking a picture with Elsa and Anna
she had a little excited
it's her second time on skates ever she
fell down she caught her finger on the
blade a little bit she it was scary
she's okay
superhero dad running in you know to
protect her I saw you running backstage
going to the bathroom and you said you
were traumatized a little bit yeah I was
traumatized when she gets traumatized
but she ultimately she's fine she's okay
those kids they certainly breathing fast
and freaking out and we got it all so we
got it all sorted little daddy-daughter
date night tonight why is it so
important for you well we actually don't
get to do that very often and I told my
wife I said my daughter has actually
just been doing a production of Annie
and she had to rehearse every Saturday
and Sunday which is typically the time
when I get to spend the most time with
her and so we wanted to make sure that
we started to do special daddy-daughter
things I mean I did special things with
my dad as a kid and my wife remembers
specifically doing a lot of special
things with her dad and one of the
reasons why she's a sports fan is
because he would take her to Rockets
games and orders games and so we just
try to do a little more of it you say
her daughter's doing a production of
Annie so she it was last weekend yes she
she has the bug huh to get into the
industry how do you feel about that
obviously very supportive I'm very
supporting I like doing things for her
that she enjoys doing so I mean we took
her to soccer and she wouldn't listen to
the coach because she was busy twirling
and dancing so I figured we figured we
try it out is it very productive a
company called grey studios and they try
to make it like a professional
production which is incredible because
she's five but she really cared a lot
about it and was excited for it so good
for her she is five what kind of advice
can you give her about you know just
living in the moment in this industry I
mean when I saw her when I saw her on
stage I noticed that she was looking to
other
castmates to get like to sort of get not
reinforcement but just make sure that
she was doing the right thing and I
tried to tell her I was like now I know
you know all this so don't worry about
looking at other people it's kind of
it's it's a family affair for all of you
guys administrate your wife was just on
the big crossover that we had Elseworlds
how was that having her you know in your
world oh it's great she need a trailer
just exciting new trailer yeah you guys
could share trailers now kid will her
character you know carry on or was that
like a one-time thing
I know that North freeze is a you know
big in the in the Batwoman universe so
hopefully I mean she had a really good
time I think she did a good job so we'll
see and she's got you right there too
it's it's not a tough day on the job now
Steven what are the holiday plans for
you in the family since I started doing
the show we always go away so we like to
go somewhere warm and warm and tropical
and we kind of pick community done st.
Barths we've done Hawaii we've done
Mireya last year in French Polynesia
always somewhere hot kind of a different
change from right here backstage of the
ice rink at the Staples Center Steven so
great to talk to you happy holidays and
enjoy that tropical vacation
[Music]